hello everybody i am very excited to be
here with christopher kazor and matthew
petrusek they are the authors of the
recent book jordan peterson god and
christianity the search for a meaningful
life which is uh published by word on
fire bishop baron's uh organization and
so i'm really happy to have them here i
have the book right here i've been
diving into it looking into it seeing
the different approaches and different
arguments so i'm happy to
have some time with them to explore why
they wrote this you know what are they
hoping to accomplish and a few of the
main points that they're trying to make
is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
christopher and matthew thank you for
coming on maybe maybe introduce
yourselves a little bit tell me what
your background is and and moving up to
why it is that you even thought of
writing such a book right now
sure so i'm a professor of philosophy at
loyola university in los angeles and i
teach a lot of courses that are related
to
subjects in faith and reason so i
actually teach a course called the god
of faith and reason and one of the big
issues that comes up with my students
again and again is how to reconcile
genesis
with contemporary science so i have many
students that are
troubled by this students who see the
attractiveness of christian faith and
then worry well i'm going to have to
jettison all contemporary knowledge
about how things evolved and whatever
so for years now i've been trying to
show students that if we put genesis
back into its proper context and read it
as a creation narrative that's a rival
to other creation narratives that
actually there's no difficulty at all in
reconciling a proper understanding of
genesis with contemporary science and
evolution and things like that
so i've been doing that for a long time
but then i ran across jordan peterson's
lectures on genesis
and i have to say even though i had read
genesis you know many many times i was
really struck and learned a ton
from his own interpretation of the text
and so i really became quite fascinated
with his work and
looked at his writings and also the
videos that he's done on other topics
and what i was struck by really was
in in my way of thinking about a
continual effort
to put contemporary science in dialogue
with
this rich faith tradition and i love
that because part of my background is
studying thomas aquinas he's one of my
great heroes and aquinas was all about
bringing together uh what was for him at
the time contemporary science that is
the writings of aristotle
with the wisdom of the christian
tradition people like john chrysostom
people like augustine of hippo and what
thomas wanted to do is bring these into
fruitful dialogue and that's what i try
to do in my own philosophical work so i
saw peterson's work really as uh another
way in a very exciting way of engaging
in this dialogue between faith and
reason so that kind of sparked my
interest in peterson and led me to write
about peterson and then eventually to
co-author this book
and so matthew you wrote the 12 rules
part uh you know not so much the
biblical lectures part so what it is
that brought you to uh such a venture
yourself
well i i did my i'm also a professor but
of a theology just right down the hall
uh from from chris at loyola marymount
university
and um i did my graduate work at the
university of chicago and it's uh it has
it rightly has the reputation of
doing a really rigorous
uh maybe even suspicious
analysis of the category of uh religion
and so it's a very sort of hard knock
intellectual environment and so when i
when i first got this job i thought oh
i'm prepared to be able to uh to speak
to students who may have some
reservations about religion in general
and christianity in particular
and i realized within the first semester
that my
estimation of where young people are
where the culture is generally
was way off i couldn't i couldn't even
assume for example that students knew
uh that the bible is composed of for
christians of the old testament the new
testament that was one assumption i
learned the first day of class
so ever since that's been about seven
years i've been looking for ways to to
re-tool uh to make religion first
accessible and then second relevant and
i've been experimenting with with
different literature and and different
approaches but when i encountered jordan
peterson's work and then saw the effect
that it was having i thought this is
this is it and i've actually been able
to test it in the classroom and sure
enough the kind of response he gets
online
uh is is also happening in the classroom
as well so
so for that reason i began engaging his
work and i also because i was giving
such a close engagement started to look
at not only areas of overlap but also
what i thought were some significant
gaps or areas in his thought that
a a substantive christian theism would
actually fix mm-hmm
and so i'm i'm curious about matthew
what
it is like what it is about his approach
that you thought
uh was in terms of christianity or in
terms of a way of living what do you
thought was so close or what would
enliven these young christian students
that you had
well
if i could play sort of armchair
psychologist which is dangerous to do
and we're talking about jordan peterson
i think that uh we're at we're at a
point now where the experiment of
secularism
is not only beginning to fail but but
really failing uh and uh and students
are young people especially are bearing
the brunt of that
uh when i think back to my to my own
youth my own coming of age and you know
when i have that long commute into work
i also often listen to music from the
90s
uh you know that's now it's considered
classic rock in some circles which is
scary but i i see i see the culture
beginning to experiment with this kind
of mischievous nihilism already
but around it people were still
basically believers in a generic sense
it was still propping up the idea that
their that life is meaningful that there
is purpose that there there is a there
is a structure to your to life in
general to your particular existence
that will hold you up so we could afford
the culture could afford to
uh to have these pockets of mischievous
nihilism well i think it's fair to say
those pockets have now become the
dominant form
and things are falling apart across the
board we see things are falling apart so
i think that there's this hunger even if
it's not
if it's not explicitly articulated by by
most a hunger for rules and then for
rules that actually have depth meaning
purpose and truth
yeah there's something funny about uh
the situation when
what happens when you know you
when the world is ordered you have room
for clowns let's say and kind of people
poking at the order but when the world
is upside down and every everything is
clownish and everything's a carnival
ah yeah what do you do
and then people who tell you to stand up
straight and pull up your pants become
whoa like this is what is this like what
is it put on your pants and then pull
them off just just put them on yeah just
that
a lot to start with
and so matt christopher in terms of of
genesis i think that for sure my own
interest
with jordan is far more in that area you
know like i i'll be honest with you i
haven't actually read 12 rules for life
but i really
his work on the
on the relationship between uh cognitive
science and kind of evolutionary biology
and the manner in which to read genesis
you know this idea of perception and the
problem of multiplicity this is what has
kind of interested me the most with
jordan what
got me excited about uh the manner in
which
he talks about it and so what it is what
is it about the way he talks about
genesis which you found connects so much
to the christian tradition
well i would say
the
in a weird in a weird way the most basic
thing was something i never noticed
until jordan peterson pointed it out to
me and that was that god creates through
rational speech
so in some of these rival creation
stories the gods have a big battle a big
war and then the universe is fashioned
out of the basically battlefield remains
of this sort of inter uh
what would you say um this war among the
gods yeah and what jordan points out
which again it's weird that i never
noticed this but that god says
let there be light
and if you think about rational speech
rational speech can only arise from some
kind of reasoner
you can't have rational speech just from
a duck quacking or uh you know a tree
falling over and making noise if it's a
rational speech there is a mind behind
it and so the universe
is arises from this rational speech and
reflects a rational mind
and
and that god repeatedly does this and
then says uh and it was good that's
another really key point because some of
these rival myths thought of the created
order as actually evil
that to have a body for example would be
seen as a bad thing an evil thing that
we should transcend and rather than view
creation in the human body as good
these other stories would say no no
you're trapped in your body your body
like plato would say your body is a
prison
that traps your soul
and i think in the christian tradition
there's this emphasis on the goodness of
creation and an emphasis on the goodness
of the human body and so again jordan
sort of highlighted these things and i
had heard the stories before but does
system never registered with me properly
and he really made it register with me
properly so i was very grateful for
those insights and then the more i
thought about those sorts of insights
about how human beings are made in the
image of god and therefore we too
express ourselves through rational
speech i mean jordan really brought that
out in a really beautiful way so i guess
what i was trying to do in the book is
connect uh peterson's interpretations of
genesis with some of these older classic
interpretations of genesis that you find
in people like origen and saint
augustine and thomas aquinas and others
and again i found this big overlap and
in some respects i thought that these
classic thinkers in a way
could really contribute and augment
what peterson was saying and bring him
kind of further down the road so in the
book that's kind of what i'm trying to
do is say this is great we're moving in
a good direction but if we look at these
these classic writers we can go even
further and even deeper
yeah i think that your point about the
the goodness of creation is a huge thing
that
seems to come up time and time again in
jordan which is
even though sometimes you wonder if he
really believes in the goodness of the
world he realizes that just like his
proposition about god that if you act as
if the world is good then the fruits of
that will be something if you act as if
the world is inherently bad then you can
also see what the fruits are and it's
interesting because you know in the past
maybe 20 years or so there's been a
resurgence of gnosticism in the popular
culture there's been in you know even in
universities this idea that the gnostics
were the real christians and that you
know orthodoxy was just suppressed all
these marginal voices of christianity
you know you you have this narrative
which is there and it's fascinating to
notice that as we kind of
see postmodernism play itself out we're
seeing in these transhuman moves and in
these even in the digital space and this
obsession with the digital space
something like uh kind of soft
narcissism where we believe that we can
exist only in these kind of subtle
bodies you know on on screens and that
you know the our our actual physical
physical bodies are something of a
obstacle to our ideal existence whether
it's in the
whether it's even in the whole uh
gender sexual identity thing but also in
other even weirder tropes like uh you
know like the
the fashion for furries and all that
kind of weird stuff where people kind of
project themselves into avatars and
things like that so i think that jordan
even in his own persona as this kind of
gritty
grounded guy he doesn't anymore but he
used to wear cowboy boots you know that
was something about like he just you
know he has this sense that he's
actually kind of standing on the ground
and his and is and speaking to you from
that that space i really think so and
also the same with with what you're
saying there there's something when
jordan's talking about scripture that
you're like
and then oh no like there's
like you're like yes yes and then i
don't know i'm not sure like here's when
things start to get a little uh yeah a
little soggy let's say uh but his
his genuineness i think is part of the
the attraction too like he's so genuine
in his desire to to kind of plunge in
and to know more and to and to move
these things around and to try to see
how they can connect to
to contemporary issues of psychology and
you know how we live in the world i
think that goes a lot to why people are
interested sometimes you know
the the christian scholar especially
speaks
speaks from a voice in which you see it
you feel almost as if this has nothing
to do with reality like this is you know
when you're talking about genesis it has
nothing to do with your life it's
nothing to do with how you live in the
world so why would you even care about
these old stories especially if they
sound so foreign to our uh to our
materialist uh thinking let's say um
yeah no i totally agree with you i think
that is part of the draw of peterson's
uh
presentation in particular when he's
actually talking hearing him talk
so when you see him and i've seen him
live twice when you see him give a talk
especially live there really is a sense
that he is thinking through these issues
he's trying to figure out what's true
and you probably noticed sometimes he'll
just stop
and it'll be like
just
you know be three or four seconds and
and you're like god did he have a stroke
i mean
i'm worried about the guy what happened
here he's still thinking
he's just sort of collecting his
thoughts and trying to pick the exactly
the right word
and for me
i appreciate that i think that's great i
mean it's he's sort of the exact
opposite of a white house press
secretary that just spits out the
talking points of the day and there's no
relationship between those talking
points or very little relationship
between those talking points and the
reality of what's actually happening
just you know
so so i love i for me that's a huge part
of uh the draw that there's a kind of
honesty a searching quality to it and
you know if you're going to search
you know sometimes you're going to not
find what you want or go in the wrong
direction but you know i think we're all
in a search i mean maybe my questions
are slightly different than jordan's but
uh you know i'm still searching i'm
still trying to grow and move forward
and
and i i love that about him and for me
frankly that's pretty inspiring i think
well look if i can
spend my life on a search
for the true the good and the beautiful
and trying to live
in accordance with the true the good and
the beautiful well then i i would think
my life is going to be pretty meaningful
and i'm going to live a pretty good life
and there's something about that which
people have a vision let's say of the
middle ages or kind of middle age
thinking of
this very rigid and solid way of
presenting things but when you look at
how actually things were done with the
contestations and the universities you
know students would bring up questions
there would be this lively debate that
would be
go on for multiple days you know where
students would just try to find
arguments to kind of
to destroy their teacher the teacher
would say like find all the arguments
you can to try to destroy my argument
and then would be this like back and
forth uh thing it was far more dynamic
and far more engaged than what we tend
to think of today
and so matthew i guess the big question
for you is what do you make of the whole
i act as if god exists thing because
that seems to be
the biggest the biggest thing the
biggest issue that keeps coming up with
jordan and he says he doesn't believe in
god but he acts as if god exists how do
you make of that in terms of of how it
connects to christianity how it how it
goes away from it or how do you how do
you see that
i think in a um
the book actually points out that uh
that
peterson's use of that of that trope i
act as if god exists is actually
something that um that pope benedict
pope benedict emeritus
encouraged as a model for uh for europe
and its waning relationship with
christianity saying at least can we
agree that it's all things considered
it's preferable for us to to live and to
act as if uh god exists and so i think i
think we can get a lot of mileage out of
that uh especially given the current
state of uh of the culture
um at the same time i think it's it's
ultimately
it it has formal a formal structure to
it but it's substantively empty because
it's hard to have a relationship with a
hypothetical and ultimately uh
christianity is is about a relationship
those are also words from from pope
benedict it's not about it's not about
us a set of propositions or a set of
ideas it's about a relationship with
jesus christ and so you you may get
something but it will be a pittance of
the actual reality that's behind it if
we only act according to the idea that
there may be some some
law giver and uh and judge it also
misses the grace it misses the it misses
the love it misses the mercy it misses
the best part
of the christian story it it gets maybe
the it might get the crucifixion but it
misses the resurrection
uh and so i think for for those reasons
it's just it's not enough theologically
philosophically but i also would say
therapeutically it's not enough because
when things get when things get dark
enough a hypothetical is not going to
carry you through it's just not going to
do it you're going to have to walk to to
jump to the other i don't like the lord
jump you're going to have to have the
courage to push through to the other
side
into an actual relationship
of faith
no i i think your point about grace is
the most important point because you
know for all my love of jordan we see
that
his
the god that he says he acts as if
exists is an ideal right is a judge as a
logos is is something towards which all
reality tends but acts as
uh as this overbearing you know model
that you have to conform to
and then this sense you know the sense
that you can't right that it actually
becomes a weight on you like this
pressure that makes you suffer because
you see it and you want to act in
conformity to it but you always fail and
so
you know it's it's actually kind of it's
actually not funny but it's kind of the
strangeness which is that the whole
point of christianity right is that this
this absolute is calling you right it's
always kind of calling you and is the
source of reality and always calling
reality back into himself
and without that even the theory even
his theory about how the world exists to
me seems to not
seems to fall apart because
there's something even behind that that
seems to even in his idea of perception
and this notion of multiplicity there
seems to be a sense in which you have to
get it
you have to understand how it's always
resolved this kind of calling in right
this bringing the world even as a person
kind of into yourself and so if you
stack that up
into higher beings then you end up with
something like like god um and so uh
my my biggest there's an interesting
thing going on too with jordan and i i
don't know if you've commented on it
either of you but uh tammy his wife is
very much closer to christianity
although she's not yet going to any
church she has been praying the rosary
every day for several years she
attributes her
her healing to a miracle that she
experienced in the hospital i'm actually
doing a series with her right now going
through the symbolism of the rosary and
which she wants to put up as a podcast
you know on her own on her own terms and
now we've heard also that michaela his
daughter is saying that she found god i
don't know exactly what that means
uh but uh but it's an interesting
situation in general to watch how how
jordan seems to have been this bridge
towards christianity for many many
people you know and it's a bridge that
he himself
has he himself has not crossed yet so i
don't know if it's something that you've
thought about in the writing of this
book
yeah a little bit um and actually kind
of after writing of the book so
one of the uh
the important things about mary it seems
to me
in jesus is if jesus is just a myth or
an ideal
uh you know an ideal or myth doesn't
need an actual mother
but
jesus was not merely an ideal or merely
the archetype but but was actually a
flesh and blood real human being and so
he had a real mother
and so i think in a way the practices
like saying the rosary
um are incredibly important for living
as if god exists so i i think that
there's something incredibly important
about living as if god exists and and i
try to do that too and there is always a
gap between
my ideals of how to live to love god
perfectly and the reality of what i
actually do
but part of the the way of of easing
this gap it seems to me is recognizing
that
it's god's help that helps us to
to
cut down on this on the gap between the
ideal and the and the real and
part of that mercy is the impetus to
prayer so when we pray it seems to me
what we're doing is enhancing that
relationship and
and
moving towards
ourselves transforming into being more
like you know how we ideally want to be
and so yeah i'm very happy to hear these
uh
encouraging uh developments about uh you
know his wife saying the rosary and i
didn't heard about his daughter but but
i think all that is really to the good
so if we act as if god exists the next
thing they ask i think would be
well
has god given any sort of revelation
about how he wants us to live and
jordan's answer to that seems to be more
or less that yeah jesus really is
somehow the ideal and teaches us
something really important about how to
live but then if that's true and we look
at the gospels jesus clearly talked
about a church and talked about the
importance of baptism and talked about
all these these things that christians
are supposed to do to to serve the poor
and to love their neighbor to forgive
their enemies and pray for their enemies
and so i think the next stage would be
well look if we try to live as if god
exists we try to follow the teachings of
jesus well then the next stage might be
well we should join a church we should
pray we should
love our enemies we should serve the
poor we should develop a life of prayer
and then and then continue moving
forward and and this way of it's not
really an intellectual way it's almost
by practice
you know that that you grow not so much
through just thinking
but but also through living through
through actual the practice of prayer
the practice of penance the practice of
serving others and so that can be and
for most people is
a very viable path to god
yeah
one of jordan's main points has been the
idea that
let's say
consciousness and perception is embodied
you know and that it it is it is very
much embodied that is the way that we
actually address the world is always
through this embodied
judging or evaluating of how things
present themselves to us you know and
this if you take that a little further
you realize that what it necessitates is
it necessitates something like ritual
there's no doubt about it that is that
if the world is teleological the way it
presents itself to us and we have to
deal with it um in terms of our purposes
then there are ways to deal with them
properly and there are ways to deal with
it which lead to death and that scales
into social interactions right we we
have ways of interacting with each other
which are ritualized and are not
arbitrary and that continues to stack up
and so all of a sudden even within
this very secular way of describing the
world things like baptism things like
communion things like
coming together singing church buildings
all the all the
the kind of stuff that the modern
d mythological d i can never say that
word the mythologizing christian wanted
to slowly eradicate
all suddenly kind of flood back in
uh and you know i think that even at the
end of his own argument jordan at some
point
has to go to church like it has to be
coming bad he can't just be talking
about embodiment but there has to be a
stacking up of how things come together
in community you know like you said all
of this is well and good unless until
you have someone you know
sitting in the pew next to you that you
really find annoying and that just gets
on your nerves all the time and now
you're faced with them and you have to
talk with them and you have to go up to
the communion
chalice at the same time knowing that
you're all part of this body um
so matthew i know if you have some
thoughts on these last few these last
few points about god
jordan has a bridge and and all of this
towards christianity
yeah one of the
again through practice having having had
the opportunity to teach uh peterson's
work a few times one of the one of the
the
the elements of his thought that
students i think react to most
positively
is uh his claim in 12 rules for life
that you have a nature
uh it comes to them as a kind of as if
it's like revelation as if as if it's
prophetic that there is a there's a way
of being
that is particular to who you are as a
human being
and i think that um
one of the reasons why that's so
revolutionary for for those who have
been uh seated and brought up in secular
culture so it's all they know it's all
they know they don't they don't have a
reference point is it's liberating
because if it's true and it is true that
we do have a nature that we are made in
a particular kind of way then the whole
life project shifts from
one of self-creation
where we are not only like a a uh a
stone carver who gets to create our own
life but we are the stone itself we're
the quarry we're the hammer we're the
chisel we're absolutely everything's
we're not working with something we are
everything that we work with at the same
time
which is
even at the most superficial level
impossible to to do well because you
have no reference points whatsoever
you're operating a vacuum
it's
at best exhausting at worst tragic and
catastrophic
so to hear that we actually have a
nature and the life project shifts from
acting in accordance with
a a general pattern of being that is
ultimately good
uh
resets
their horizon of what is possible then
on top of that if you can build into
that
that notion of creation this
sacramentality and this this
incarnational understanding of god being
present in bodies in matter in stuff
well then there you go you've got a good
religion at that point and you also have
orthodox christianity yeah as well
pretty much yeah pretty much uh and so
i'm gonna i want to ask the big question
you know this
in the last few months uh jordan has
really been talking a lot about
psychedelics uh he's had quite a few
experts some people even claiming you
know that the original eucharist would
have been hallucinogen
you can feel by my tone what i think of
this stuff but
i wanted to know
but this is a big deal like i don't want
to also make people's uh reaction via
the way people are dealing with this
even in my own the own people that watch
my videos uh this is a big thing because
this is coming back into culture and
jordan also seems to be if not
encouraging it talking a lot about it in
ways that will encourage it whether he
wants to or not um
what do you see to be the difference or
or maybe you don't but what do you see
to be the difference between this vision
of spirituality which is this taking of
or take or having spiritual experiences
seeing the sky open up you know having
all these all these uh these types of
experiences and the the spirit the
christian walk like the christian
transformation
yeah i think one way of thinking about
it would be the difference between a
kind of selfish orientation versus a
kind of altruistic orientation so if i
take drugs
what i especially hallucinogens i'm
cutting myself off from reality and i'm
having my own kind of private experience
but in so far as i'm cut off from
reality that makes it much more
difficult
at least when i'm cut off to really love
god
to really love other people and even
really to love myself
and the reason is that real love has to
be based on reality
real love is based on truth if i want to
if we think of love as
willing the good of the other for their
sake in order for me to do that i have
to know truly who this other person is
and i have to know the truth about what
is actually good for this person and
even loving myself if i'm gonna love
myself properly i have to know the truth
about who i am and the truth about what
would actually be good for me
so insofar as i am you know on lsd or
something and i'm detached from reality
that obscures
my ability to know the truth about
myself the truth about other people uh
and the truth about god so i think the
christians thought let me just be fair
for the people taking i've never taken
the messages but let me be fair to the
argument which is that what they say is
that when you do take it it's the
opposite which happens yeah that that
what you encounter is more reality as
you see the reality more you see a
deeper reality of yourself you see a
deeper reality of the world and you also
see a deeper reality of others so a lot
of people it's not always the case but
some people like sam harris for example
says that his whole spiritual
journey started when he took the he took
dmt i think and then all of a sudden he
felt this deep love like this
this like overwhelming love for his
friend that he couldn't explain that was
so completely uh taken taking him over
and that when he finished his trip then
he wanted more of that like he just
wanted more of that so i just want to be
fair to the to the to the to the
psychedelic people yeah yeah no that's
fair enough that's fair enough and i
haven't taken lsd either so i i can't
comment you know one way or the other
but i guess
if we move off harris's insight there is
something beautiful and wonderful about
feeling
love for other people and that's
terrific but at the end of the day i'd
say the christian ideal is not so much
feeling and emotion
but being a certain kind of person
and because you're a certain kind of
person you act in a certain kind of way
so the christian ideal it seems to me is
jesus and it ultimately is about love
and love at the end of the day it seems
to me in this fallen world is going to
involve suffering so in a way the
opposite of feeling good is going to
involve in some cases feeling a great
deal of suffering
and again that's not the end of the
story the christian story is that the
suffering of jesus wasn't the end that
he did suffer grievously but that you
know the story continues and we have the
resurrection we have that great joy
and i think that my way of thinking
about at least is that my the goal of my
life should not be to feel a certain way
or to have certain experiences but the
goal of my life should be love i should
try to love god i should try to love
other people i should try to love myself
properly and i will have
deep important experiences and deep
feelings if i do that i mean the more i
love other people the more i care about
them the more i have a feeling
of love towards them so feelings are
important i'm not denying that but i
think that
if we put feelings in the first place
and chase after feelings i think that's
going to get us into trouble i think the
better way to move is to try to love and
if we do try to love others
authentically i think we will in a very
natural way have very deep uh important
and positive experiences uh with these
people yeah i think i think you've got
exactly the right point at least in my
perception which is that it really is a
difference between
experience in a passive way
and you know embodied practice in the
other which is that
you know the difference between
receiving an experience and just kind of
having it and then actually walking on a
road and being transformed as you walk
on this path you know and i think that
that's it seems that well you can be
tricked to believe one is the other
because you have this elated experience
of reality and you you get a sense that
you pierce the veils and the mysteries
that are holding the world together you
think that somehow that's you
you know and then when you're done you
go back to your miserable little
uh life and you don't you don't
necessarily realize that when it hits
the road loving your neighbor doesn't
like you said mean feeling all these
things about it means actually engaging
with them in a certain way which which
includes self-sacrifice and includes all
of this and so i i totally agree there
even in the mystical tradition of the
christian the christian church like in
the orthodox tradition you have a sense
in which
these mystics they have these crazy
spiritual experiences like in you know
all these
very similar to the ones people have on
on on these drugs but they tell you
ignore those experiences
don't don't don't
they'll happen just let them go actually
let them go don't don't bother with them
because that's not your goal your goal
is not to have these it's actually your
goal is to become in the image of god
your goal is to become like christ not
to just have these experiences so
matthew i don't know if you have some
thoughts on this same subject yeah it's
it's it's cheating
it's cheating pure and simple i mean
it's
you can win it by cheating but you've
still cheated and so if it's true that
god exists and i think that god does
exist and if it's true that jesus christ
is the son of god which i believe to be
true
then
it's the ultimate cheat i mean you're
you want the resurrection without the
cross and jesus is very very clear
that that is not the way to go that that
is the way to perdition not to salvation
and i think that's not because that's
just the way that god has happened to
rig the system uh that you have to
suffer in order to make it but stuff
that's just the nature of of
of real transformation of real
individual transformation is if you're
not capable of
of saying yes to god of saying yes to
christ in the middle of the darkness if
you need to trip in order to say yes to
god well then you don't love god you
love yourself
and and you've just now
now participated in a
mystical delusion of what's ultimately
just an expression of of self-love
so it's i mean i i even have what you're
saying is so so interesting because
jordan had this interview with this this
mushrooms guy
and uh it was it was some guy who was
saying i forget what his name is he was
saying that all religion was based on
mushrooms and he was interviewing this
other person he was obviously someone
who had done a lot of mushrooms like a
lot of psychedelics and they talked
about it for two hours and then finally
jordan asked this person and i'm sorry
if he ever watches this but he asked
this person so what is it about
until now they're just talking about the
actual mushrooms like it's hard for me
to even focus that long on something
like that but then they come to saying
like what is it about like what's behind
all of this and the man answers
something like you realize that after
you've been all through this you know it
like like you've gone through you
realize that god doesn't exist and it's
just you and i was like yeah
that's it
you're just waiting
is the final salute and i and when i say
solipsism it's not even it's really is
like yeah you you need to understand
what the consequences of solipsism are
that it's not just i'm not just being a
religious rigorous and saying it's wrong
like there are actual fruits of
solipsism and they look like our world
today and so that's the end of this
stuff is something like solipsism
yeah and you think of dante's uh
inferno right the the people that are in
the deepest part of hell are frozen in
ice so sort of like an image of
solipsism right they're just inward just
themselves no actual contact with
another person
uh that that is at least for dante the
very worst
ending situation right to be in the
pitiful which is not for him fire but to
be totally encased in ice yeah exactly
you can all of dante's hell until then
is about love it's about it's all about
love but it's about ill-placed love and
misplaced love but then when he gets to
the deepest pit it's like that's when
the love is gone then that's it all
that's left is this these frozen lac
these undynamic realities that can't you
know can it can't transcend themselves
into others and so it's just the the
flip side of that kind of ecstasy is
despair i mean and it's it's paper thin
of of one side to the other because if
you end up by yourself and that's all
there is that's also hell
absolute terror yeah and the idea that
this would be used as a therapeutic to
help people cope with reality it's awful
it's awful i mean it's i can't i can't
stress how much if anybody's watching
this who's thinking about experimenting
with drugs as a way of dealing with
depression or anxiety please don't
you will end up alone in hell
matthew can you tell us what you really
think i'm you're holding back and i'm
just i'm unclear you know it's like it's
like can you be any clearer
all right all right so i think i think
on that last little moment of of uh of
passion i i think we can finish this
everybody
i you check out the book jordan peterson
god and christianity uh you can find it
everywhere um and it's also one more of
the great things that word on fire is
doing you know all the work they're
doing with uh
connecting to the secular world and so
maybe you can finish in telling me a
little bit about uh the reaction you've
had uh you know from the book and then
we'll finish there so so please tell me
a bit about how people are reacting to
it
i i think the reaction that i've uh had
at least has been very positive
i've had
actually the opportunity to go to the
vatican and gave a copy
of the book to the pope he seemed very
happy about it i don't know now does he
know jordan peterson i'm not sure but
but he seemed delighted with it but in
terms of people who had actually read
the book um i've been very encouraged on
amazon at least uh the last time i
checked there were about 70 reviews
already and uh the i think it was 4.8
out of 5 stars or something so that's
like you know that's really good i think
so i think that i've been very happy
with the reaction so far
i i i have as well um there there is uh
speaking
personally there is a kind of
evangelical um
aspiration in this book that i i i think
i think it's fair to say for chris as
well that we hope this book not only uh
shows um
christians how how peterson i think is
an ally and a true ally in a very robust
ally um but also also those coming from
the petersonian side as it were who uh
who may be interested in christianity
because of him that there is a way there
is a there is an ending to this story
that illuminates the whole story and
puts a foundation beneath it and and
makes it a true adventure and so and so
i i'm hoping that the the book has that
effect with some people and it appears
it might be all right well thank you for
doing this thank you for your book and
uh looking forward to seeing how people
react to all this everybody check out
the book thank you for your attention
and we'll talk to you very soon